hey everybody welcome back to the gains
but stage in the final day of e3 i'm
your host cam Robinson here for the next
two hours for I hand back to Chris
waters or way no I think Daniel doir is
taking this stage home at the end but
i'm joined right now by mr. Matt hate me
hate in Matt good to have you on stage
so Matt what is a beautiful game that
you make it lots of people play online
and shoot each other yeah that's right
planetside 2 it's a massively
multiplayer first-person shooter allow
thousands of players to directly and
simultaneously fight with each other in
massive battles that use air vehicles
ground vehicles intense infantry action
all that takes place in 64 square
kilometer continents so enormous
handcrafted Maps the players are able to
play on and you know it's a persistent
free-to-play a shooter game it's
available now on the pc and we're going
to be bringing it this year to the
playstation 4 haha that's why you're
here right but that's like that's going
to talk about that loads of people being
enjoying on the pc like I mean if you
look at the I was looking at you know
someone like the reviews adversity like
did this are for this game is huge like
how big is your audience on PC uh you
know we have a lot of players and when I
think the main reasons is because
there's just not another game like
planetside 2 out there when we first
started talking about planetside 2 we
had all these players who would really
love the original game you know and they
had they said hey I really love an MMO
FPS game but nothing else came along
that really gave them that experience
until planetside 2 came out so we kind
of had this almost like captive
passionate dedicated audience that was
just waiting for the next big thing and
ever since we've started working on
planetside 2 those guys have been great
they've been it's been growing
planetside 2 has far more players and
planetside one ever had and you know
every every day we're listening to our
players trying to add new stuff for them
and trying to grow the game and exactly
the way that they wanted to get grow
okay so before we come on is exactly
what it's gonna be like on the
PlayStation 4 and while you know orders
the ps4 can expect for planetside 2
let's just in case anyone watching you
never heard of the game were never
played it let's kind of go into detail
about how it works okay so if you're if
you're gonna if i was to sign up right
now the play how it go through will be
the first thing i do so right now what
you would do is you would go to
planetside 2 calm you would sign up for
an account and you would download it
okay and depending on your internet
connection I a few minutes to a few
hours later you would be able to jump
right into the game and depending on how
good your pc is
you would be able to run it at settings
like we're seeing here this is running a
pretty ultra graphics settings yeah but
obviously you can go all the way down
but this this would be the equivalent of
what players on the ps4 would expect to
see this kind of level of graphic
fidelity and then in planetside 2
there's three different empires that you
select from each one has access to
unique vehicles unique weapons kind of
its own style of the way that they
approach combat and you choose an empire
you put your character in and you have a
persistent character that you then can
play forever you can add you know
hundreds of hours of customization and
personalization into the game by you
know getting your kit set up exactly the
way that you want for your vehicles or
for your infantry there's so much depth
to the different roles that are
available for you to unlock and play and
it's all available for free right from
the get-go fantastic so when you when
you make that choice because it's the
three factions all right there's a bit
like the kind of Kelsey ones there's
like the rebel ones and then there's the
army ones right i Kenned up the pretty
clothes pretty much I pretty much yeah
have you don't mind my real simple way
of breaking it down there no I like
that's pretty good once you make that
choice can you change Allegiance are you
liked hidin that's one of the only
choices in the game that's kind of
permanent to your care okay when you
create a character your gender your name
and the Empire that you're playing on as
well as the server that you're playing
on are pretty much fixed but once you
make those decisions any class that you
want to play if you want to try playing
a light assault for instance you can
play as a light assault and then if you
need to be an engineer no problem you
can go to an equipment terminal switch
to an engineer kit you could put
hundreds of hours in your engineer kit
and switch over to a heavy assault when
you're wanting to try that out you can
go earn certification points as a as a
max or as a light assault and spend them
on making your vehicle's better if you
want to it's very freeform very open and
it's all designed around allowing
players to fill the role that is needed
right now for their team planetside at
the end is a team-based game it's
thousands of people fighting against
each other so no matter how great you
are at an FPS game you're probably not
going to be able to win it a fight
against 200 dudes one player can do a
lot in the game you could definitely
have our our hero players that are able
to like wipe the floor with you know
squads and stuff but when you're working
together with dozens of players hundreds
of players to accomplish big goals it's
a really impressive amazing feeling
having you know dozens of guys all
cresta ridgid
heading for an objective is something
you just don't get in any other game
period so that team play aspect and the
player customization aspect really work
together you have your guy kitted out to
do exactly what your team needs right
now you can be an individual in that but
you're also helping out your group and
helping out your team helping out your
empire fantastic so many well what are
we looking at here which can I describe
what some of the gameplay that's going
in here so is this like this like a
mashup right yeah this is cut like
vehicles so you find them legit about
the the the environments or do you just
can't purchase them or how does it out
the way it works is in planetside 2 you
capture territory so it's a completely
persistent game again so when you go and
capture a base in the game that base now
is your base until someone comes and
takes it away from you and while your
empire owns that base all the players on
that Empire earning resources for it
those resources you could spend to get
things like this max suit that we see on
screen here the vehicles that we were
seeing earlier all wondering how you get
those suitors like some guys look like
really much more powerful but that is
from unlocks that's basically a lot in
gameplay so it's it's not something that
you unlock permanently but you spend
resources for it when you want to get it
and then when it dies it's gone but
those resources are earned by what your
empire is doing in the world so that's
how the strategic game kind of attaches
to the moment-to-moment gameplay gotcha
and you see here all these different
vehicles and infantry that we're seeing
in the game unlike a lot of other
shooters every single thing you see is
another player it's all one hundred
percent pvp so when you see fifty
airplanes flying overhead doing bombing
runs those are all filled up with dudes
that you could go like you can go be
allies with you can go up and shoot all
those dudes it's not just like some
cutscenes so everything you're seeing
here is one hundred percent driven by
the combined arms strategy of players
actually playing the game this is just a
capture on a live server this wasn't
some coordinated gameplay where we were
like hey we need these 600 extras to
come and log in so we can film a trailer
right and possible this go on the live
server with it with a camera account and
follow around fights and capture footage
this is what normal flights and planets
I to look like so you just in like a
ghost cam just flying around data right
we go find a couple big fights and film
footage for a few hours that's how we
make these trailers they're not
attempted to be like a coordinated you
know ya know filmed thing so you said
it's like this I'm kind of persistent
persistent world so is there like a huge
territory map that changes dynamically
every time there's like a fight is
solutely one inside of the other each
one of our continents is 64 square
kilometers of handcrafted gameplay space
they have anywhere from fifty to a
hundred different bases on it depending
on which continent that you're on you
know yeah so each one of those bases can
be captured and owned by one of the
Empire's and they are constantly
contentious so you have these battle
fronts that just move based on where
enemies are deciding to push way
somewhere your empires deciding to push
sometimes they'll let you push a few
bases and not like try to resist until
it gets to a key base that they really
want to hold if they have a defensive
strategy for and you have to break it so
it's again it's entirely set up and
entirely driven by players and their
strategies for capturing these different
bases there's very few um kind of
barriers between players that we've kind
of erected to say oh you can't fight
here right now it's more like we slam
players into each other and let them
push around the map however they want
fantastic so these empires the three
that you can choose from how do they
affect how you're gonna play the game
from from the offset is there different
weapons different vehicles lots of stuff
that you can get hold of depending on
who you choose yeah I mean they kind of
have we want you to be able to enjoy the
game no matter which one of the Empire's
you choose so we have very specific
Empire wet weapons and games but they
also kind of blend into each other a
little bit ly some things that everyone
can use and some weapons everyone can
get but they travel each Empire will
have a few things oh I am look I like to
kind of describe it like a Venn diagram
right so if you look at like all the
assault rifles in the game you can think
of them like a Venn diagram the highest
damage ones are over on the new
conglomerate but the other two empires
get high damage ones too maybe not as
much they don't have this much emphasis
on high damage low firing rate right the
Terran Republic one of our other empires
are sort of the opposite less damage
very low recoil very controllable
weapons but very fast fire rates high
ammo capacity right so they're kind of
on the opposite end of the Venn diagram
and then the banu sovereignty is all
about weapons that are kind of easy to
manage they allow for mobility and they
allow for a lot of different
configurations so they kind of have they
have the ability to sort of switch their
weapons up and have them play in a lot
of different roles so they have
adaptability kind of so you can kind of
think of them as being down here but
there's a lot of crossover in the middle
so if you really like close quarters
combat you're not going to be asked out
because you're on the new conglomerate
you're going to be able to get a weapon
that allows you to function really well
as it as a
close quarters now it might not be as
good as the best close-quarters weapon
that the TR can get and then you have
all these really cool counterbalances of
when I'm fighting against the Terran
Republic they have this kind of max when
I'm fighting against the NC they have
this kind of max so the way that you're
fighting against each other is a little
bit different the way the armor you know
interacts with each other is a little
bit different and that creates these
sort of asymmetrical strategies that you
use while you're fighting different
troops so does that mean sometimes you
get old three factions like fighting at
the same time buying overwhelm base so
it's not just like one versus the other
all three are in there trying to capture
the same point yeah the way our base
design works in the way the flow on our
continents works yeah we have kind of
lanes almost where these bases sort of
connect to each other in a certain way
and these other bases kind of connect to
each other in a certain way and some
lanes kind of encourage three-way fights
and other lanes kind of encourage more
two-way fights because these enemies are
coming from these sides around like this
all right well let's talk places before
dress that's the big news here so what's
been like bring it to ps4 is there
anything that people who play on ps4
gonna get the people who play on PC
don't is it like the exact same
experience all that kind of stuff um
well our plan right now is to bring the
entire pc game over to the ps4 whole hog
and the biggest difference the players
are going to see if you were to load up
planetside 2 right now put it on ultra
settings put it at 1080p and run it on
your TV that's almost the experience
that you're going to be getting on the
ps4 we're running right now on 1080p
we're peaking over 60 frames per second
we still have a lot of optimization to
do the biggest difference that you would
notice is the user interface because
we're completely taking all of these big
deep MMO menus and we're making them be
accessible and easy to use on the
gamepad on the DualShock 4 and so kind
of our entire like our largest goal with
the entire process right now bringing
the game over to the ps4 is to make it
not feel like a console port we wanted
to feel like a native triple a console
game that just happens to be completely
free and happens to have thousands of
players and persistence and all the
other things the planets I do that does
that no other game does fantastic so am
actually we did through a little to
throw it to Twitter didn't we just
before we came on live so yeah we'll
check to see if anyone has sent in some
questions I think we might have yeah we
certainly seem to have a few here Oh yep
fantastic so fresh
for a frontier hawkins is there any kind
of squad heresy I'm sorry hierarchy like
private general etc so can you level up
in your squad as you go so in squads we
don't we have a squad leader and then we
also have the other 11 members of the
squad and the squad leader can assign
somebody else to be a squad leader if
you want there's lots of cool things
that you can do with your squad but
where we do have that functionality is
in outfits and outfits kind of create
the the backbone of the team play and
planetside 2 outfits are our equivalent
of guilds if you're familiar with guilds
from other MMO games so in an outfit you
absolutely can set all kinds of
different permissions for who can invite
people into the outfit what type of
things they can do can they add our new
outfit recruitment system that we're
about to put into the game to allow
player outfits to say this is the type
of outfit we are here's when we play
we're looking for recruits and then
players can browse doesn't find those so
permissions for that is something that
you know the outfit can set so all those
permissions are in there and it really
allows for players to again it's a team
play game it really is about working
together and coordinating with other
players so that team play aspect is
really really emphasized with the outfit
gameplay fantastic well Matt it's being
pleasure having you on stage thanks so
much for coming on man I toss about
minus i2 so you can play it right now
you play right now just go to planetside
2 calm right now download that damn game
play out let us know Vic keep watching
this duck you to open a new tab after e3
coverage no known you tabs go to chat
new tab go